I have to tell you and I think I've told
you this before and I ate it every time
I hear it okay but I got started on sir
not live and that was one of my earliest
writing gigs and when I went for the
interview Lauren Michaels said who's
your favorite performer on Starr not
live and I said Kevin Nealon and I was
because I just really loved I just loved
your dry style your subtlety your wit
and then I got to work with you but I
don't know how you got the gig in the
first place I don't know how you got
sound out live well they asked me who my
favorite writer was mm-hmm and I said a
young man by that name of Conan O'Brien
you don't know him yet you hadn't met me
when you thought that yeah so what
happened Conan was Dana Carvey a friend
of mine yeah and on Saturday Night Live
that summer for that yeah he was your
friend Dana was your friend and he got
on the show first that's right yes
you're a good listener
so what happened was they were looking
for one more
and Dana recommended me uh-huh and and
they and I knew I'd never get it cuz I
was just a stand-up comic I didn't do
sketch work or anything or characters
and so they need one more guy so they
fly me and I'm thinking it's gonna just
be me and maybe somebody else for that
one one part I get on the plane
everybody on the plane is going in to
audition for that one part you know even
the pilot comes out of the cockpit hey
you think this is funny I'm gonna come
on and and I get there and I'm not
nervous about but you know it all
started when Dana called me that summer
from Laura Michael's house
he calls me goes calf guess where I am
I'm in the back bedroom of Lorne
Michaels house and I'm Long Island
they're looking for one more cast member
and guess who's in the kitchen Chevy
Chase and Dan Aykroyd I said you're
kidding me yes No
anyway they need one more one more cast
number and I told them about you I think
they're gonna want to see your tapes I
said Dan Aykroyd and Chevy Chase are in
the kitchen because yeah I gotta go
somebody's coming you know yeah I sent
my tapes and never thought I would get
it and and then they calls me like two
weeks later Michael's house again this
is in the kitchen it's Paul Simon and
Chevy Chase see you're kidding me no I
think they like your tapes and they
couldn't fly in for an audition
Chevy Chase Danny we're in the kitchen
now yeah so you know I fly in and I do
the audition and didn't think I would
get it was just a free trip to New York
I loved it I go back to Los Angeles and
three weeks later guess where I am
Lauren Michaels kitchen I got a phone
call
guess where Dana was where was Dana back
bedroom
he calls me up guess who's in the
kitchen I said I'm in the kitchen what
was your first sketch concert at live it
was mr. subliminal did you audition like
that is that part of it part of it I
didn't know you like that kiss up that's
good but um yeah so I was about ready to
go on and do that and it's kind of a
tongue twister to do that so here we am
ready to go on live TV Saturday Night
Live and four seconds away they're
coming back from commercial and Lauren
Michaels puts his hand on my shoulder
and goes are you sure this is what you
want he has a way of doing that yeah
let's just see me wandering the halls
like at four o'clock in the morning hich
say still with the show wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]